we've got some breaking news um
out of washington dc
the us supreme court there have
overturned
the landmark roe versus wade ruling that
ruling legalized abortion
nationwide and we're trying to go to
our correspondent martha kellner who's
outside the us supreme court in
washington
sir martha roe versus wade has been
overturned
[Applause]
it certainly has this is a seismic
moment for life and law in america you
can see
behind me the protesters gathering here
some of them celebrating and hugging
those are the pro-life crowds those who
are anti-abortion there are also people
here who are devastated those are the
pro-choice pro-abortion
campaigners they've been waiting for
this moment waiting to hear what the
supreme court decided on this hugely
consequential case
they were expecting this decision we had
a draft opinion which was leaked last
month to an american political website
politico which indicated that the
supreme court justices which are the
highest
judges in the land were minded to
overturn the landmark roe versus wave
ruling which legalized abortion
nationwide in america
that this has now been confirmed doesn't
make it any less of an earthquake
just to put it into context this
dismantles
50 years of legal precedent it was 1973
when women across america were given the
right to choose abortion that has now
been reversed from today
many many millions of women across
america will no longer have the right to
access abortion it's been taken away
from the constitution it's the first
time in history a constitutional right
like this has been
removed
as of today we expect that 25 or 26 of
the 50 states
in america will severely restrict
orban abortion vast swathes of the
southern states of america the likes of
texas louisiana arkansas mississippi
also vast waves of the midwest places
like missouri michigan wisconsin places
where millions and millions of women
live they will no longer have the right
to access abortion as they did
yesterday
it really is a massive
massive moment for america it's
something that pro-life anti-abortion
campaigners
have been asking for
for decades and it's been made possible
by a newly right-leaning supreme court
if i can just briefly explain the
make-up of the supreme court it's the
nine highest judges in the land and they
affect uh they affect the biggest legal
decisions in the land and it's now more
conservative leaning than it has been
for decades that's because when former
president donald trump was in charge he
appointed three conservative supreme
court justices to the court
they are determined uh to take this
court more right-leaning and as such
they made the decision yesterday
which expanded gun rights today they've
taken the decision to reverse
abortion rights
it really does mean that america already
so bitterly divided will become
even more divided there will be two
different americas when it comes to
abortion
it's roughly divided like the electoral
maps so you might see
blue states and red states lit up on
that electoral map that you'll remember
from presidential
election nights it roughly follows the
same trend when it comes to abortion so
the red states the republican states
will further restrict or even ban
completely abortion whereas the blue
states
will uh maintain access to abortion so
you'll have this divided america where
women living in blue states will
continue to be able to access abortion
whereas women
living in red states will no longer be
able to access abortions unless they can
afford to travel across state lines so
you'll have a situation where rich women
living in republican states will have
access to abortion women in democrat
states will have access to abortion but
poor women living in republican states
disproportionately women of color will
no longer have access to abortion and
there really is the potential for this
country to become even more vitally
divided
because of this historic decision today